welcome to this video playing fantasy
yeah played him before with the loss no
I have some weird feeling that it wasn't
it was a strange game or something
something it's something weird happening
I don't know what it was
okay I'm playing this this line and I
recently had a strange game with this
maybe against the same guy I don't know
okay
trying to pray play a bit quick ahem
not spending spending ages it's a very
unspectacular position anyway this c6
line is a very good antidote against h4
I'd really am yeah pretty much
and stops any any ambitious play by
white there really should should give up
this move if people start to realize
that c6 is simply okay you get this kind
of position all the time but black has
two bishops and you really I don't know
what what you're doing okay um b5 yeah
at least
this is weakening the Queen side a bit
nothing serious but maybe some some kind
of idea for what a for maybe hmm maybe a
for before might be one it's not very
very great I go before they form
yeah it's not really really great maybe
I can can double first maybe night be
one something like that okay
you know my ideas to play um night b1
and b3 to get the night out I need to
attend the door just do it
okay this cost some time but what can
you do
what's the mailman I got some sort of
package I don't know what it is okay
no chess book that I would have known
okay I'm got the night out from from
seafoam it might come to your form it's
it's really it's not a position where
Jack white can can hope for anything
it's really a very unspectacular I have
some weak dark squares I should have
like Quincy to first ah this was bad
yeah nothing terrible but I don't really
need to to let him in them okay I can go
Quincy to next
yeah he's got two bishops but I have a
healthy structure so I think we are
about about equal here if I go here no I
should I should look at those squares
first maybe 9075
can can be an idea
it's not really doing much but it's also
important to to play relatively quickly
here as time will become an issue okay
how to continue here
there's really no big active way to play
nice maybe threatening to take that
trying to isolate the pawn maybe
yeah that's still it's still not very
comfortable against the against the two
bishops oops no the King over to d2 to
help on the Queen side
I mean ninety-four provoke the F pawn to
move but I can also play e5 here but
okay I can take that an idea three it
should be okay check check check
times they played before I don't know
tough with this little time and of
course I'm under pressure in a way maybe
I could have taken play 94 trying to set
up a total blockade
94 now
they five cornices only weakness Jack I
think he needs to I just not thought you
needed to take it it's hard to how to
keep the porn protected here
we can go 94 eye candy for me
the ideas night f3m Jack yeah okay this
is the drawing but Jack
oh no no no I'm getting the beef up on
Jack still it oh of course
Jack I think yeah it's very difficult to
do anything here with white I didn't see
that but okay jack
yeah how do I get rid of the pieces him
I don't see it from silent check draw
offered draw off her game yeah I don't
know after he gave after he lost the
pawn
maybe there's wind somewhere but in no
time at all I let him become very active
here I didn't see a king detorri I need
to play Bishop a6 him then 93 then was
winning but okay the whole game was very
one-sided in a way like had a very
comfortable end game yeah h4 is really
completely diffused by c6 after that
it's a very Jack Jack Jack very
prospectus position in a way for white
yeah here I don't know it's all this
dough should be a draw with a good
defense but check check yeah he went
right into 92 him after that
I really should show Jenny but okay it
has no relation whatsoever to their to
the game before if he plays something
else it's just just equal I guess with
opposite colored bishops black has some
some symbolic advantage with the space
space advantage but probably you draw
anyway yeah if we look at the opening
it's really in the case that c6 is some
a very good move for for for this line
after h4 it's not very green fair dish
in a way you want to play c5 and stuff
but it's probably the right way to to
simply tell wider kh4 everything's good
but what exactly are you doing there if
I just keep a good center
and the white is basically playing with
this move h4 which does not make much
sense in a Slav at least I don't like it
at all
okay thanks for watching